في هذه الأثناء، سيتم نقل 31 طفلاً حديث الولادة
من مستشفى الشيفر
إلى مصر في
الساعات القادمة، وقد تم إجلاؤهم يوم الأحد من قبل
فريق الأمم المتحدة
والهلال الأحمر الفلسطيني ونقلهم إلى
مستشفى الولادة في جنوب غزة،
وتقول اليونيسف إن حالتهم مستقرة.
تتدهور بسرعة بسبب
انهيار الخدمات الطبية في الحياة
وفقًا لمنظمة الصحة العالمية،
ويقول الأطباء الذين يعالجونهم الآن إن جميع الأطفال يعانون من
إصابات خطيرة و11 منهم في
حالة حرجة. أحد الآباء
الذين تم لم شملهم مع ابنه الوليد
بعد أسبوعين يقول إنه لم يكن متأكدًا مما إذا
كان طفله لا يزال على قيد الحياة
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
آل
[موسيقى]
وينضم إلي الآن ساري باشي،
مدير البرنامج في هيومن رايتس ووتش،
شكرًا جزيلاً على  تخصيص الوقت
أردت أن أسألك عن الأطفال الذين
تم إجلاؤهم من مستشفى ألفا الذي يقع
بالطبع تحت السيطرة الإسرائيلية،
أعني أن الإخلاء يعد خبرًا جيدًا
ولكن العديد من المستشفيات والمرافق الصحية الأخرى
أصبحت الآن غير قادرة فعليًا على
العمل وآخر الأرقام  من
الجرحى أكثر من 30.000 ما هي
مخاوفك في هذا الصدد
العلاج بالتأكيد لذلك توفر قوانين الحرب
حماية خاصة
للمدنيين بشكل عام وخاصة
للمستشفيات والمرافق الطبية الأخرى
المستخدمة لعلاج المرضى
والجرحى في إسرائيل على حد سواء  يقع على عاتق الطرف الحربي
وكذلك قوة
الاحتلال
واجب حماية المستشفيات
وتسهيل
عملها بشكل جيد حتى قبل مداهمة مستشفى الشفاء والمستشفيات
الأخرى، فقد
توقفت عن العمل كمستشفيات لأن
الجيش الإسرائيلي قام بشكل منهجي
باستنزاف غزة من الموارد المنقذة للحياة.
الإمدادات الإنسانية بما في ذلك الوقود اللازم لتشغيل
حاضنات الأطفال ثم أخبرنا المزيد عن
تدفق لا شك أن ما
يدخل ليس قريبًا بما يكفي
للناس في الجنوب أه ولكن هل
تصل أي مساعدات إلى أولئك الذين بقوا في
الشمال  جزء من غزة، لم
يتمكن الجميع بالطبع من الفرار من الجنوب حيث
طالبت إسرائيل بما يجب تحسينه من خلال
حجم المساعدات ولكن أيضًا
التوزيع المؤكد، لذلك
سمح الجيش الإسرائيلي أولاً بدخول ما
يزيد قليلاً عن ألف شاحنة محملة خلال 44
يومًا من الحرب إلى غزة.  غزة، هذا هو
نفس المبلغ تقريبًا الذي كان يدخل خلال
يومين إلى غزة في الأوقات العادية
عندما لم يكونوا يواجهون تحديات غير عادية.
ثانيًا،
أبقى الجيش الإسرائيلي معابره مع
غزة مغلقة، وهذا هو سبب
انخفاض الأعداد للغاية  منع دخول الوقود تقريبًا
تحتاج الجيش الإسرائيلي
إلى إعادة فتح معابرها التجارية
مع غزة كما فعلت في
الأعمال القتالية السابقة رفع الحظر المفروض على الوقود والسماح بدخول
الوقود وغيره من
الإمدادات المنقذة للحياة إلى غزة
وتسهيل تدفق المساعدات بشكل نشط  من
الجنوب إلى الشمال لأن جميع
المعابر التجارية تقع في
الجنوب وقد تم عزل هاتين المنطقتين
من قبل القوات الإسرائيلية